♪ ♪
>> Laura: IF DEMS TAKE THE
WHITE HOUSE, THAT IS THE FOCUS
OF TONIGHT'S ANGLE.
SERIOUS TIMES REQUIRE A SERIOUS
LEADERSHIP, AND THE LAST FEW
DAYS HAVE FURNISHED US WITH
AMPLE REASONS FOR WHY DEMOCRATS
SHOULD GET NOWHERE NEAR THE
OVAL OFFICE.
AS THE BORDER CHRIST        CRIE
AS THE BORDER CHRIST        CRIP
AS THE BORDER CHRIST        CRIN
AS THE BORDER CHRIST        CRI,
AS THE BORDER CHRIST        CRIA
RECORD 100,000 BORDER
APPREHENSIONS IN APRIL.
THIS IS WHAT JOE BIDEN IS
THINKING.
>> I THINK THAT ANYONE,
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER THEY ARE
DOCUMENTED OR UNDOCUMENTED, WE
HAVE AN OBLIGATION.
THAT IS WHY WE NEED MORE
CLINICS.
>> Laura: MORE CLINICS,
HEALTH CARE FOR ILLEGALS.
WHY SHOULD ANYBODY BE SURPRISED?
AFTER ALL, IT WAS THE
OBAMA-BIDEN WHITE HOUSE THAT
REWARDED HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF ILLEGALS WITH DAC A WORK
STATUS.
ACCORDING TO FEDERAL DATA
OBTAINED BY BREITBART NEWS, U.S.
TAXPAYERS ALREADY PAY ABOUT A
QUARTER OF A BILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY TO PROVIDE HEALTH CARE
TO ILLEGALS WHO ARE IN ICE
CUSTODY.
BUT THAT IS NOTHING WHEN
COMPARED TO THE 17 BILLION --
YES, WITH A B -- THAT AMERICANS
PAY IN MEDICAL CARE TO ILLEGALS
WHEN LIVING INSIDE THE
UNITED STATES.
I HAVE A
BIDEN'S SOLUTION IS TO HAVE
CLINICS AND MAKE THE TRIP EVEN
MORE ATTRACTIVE TO THEM ACROSS
THE BORDER.
THAT MEANS THAT SADDLING YOU
WITH THE BILL.
WHEN BIDEN WAS A VP, ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION NUMBERS WERE
STAGGERING.
REMEMBER, THE UNACCOMPANIED
MINORS CRISIS IN 2014 WAS A
NIGHTMARE, BUT FIVE YEARS LATER,
THE FORMER VP IS, WELL, BLAME
SHIFTING.
>> IT'S A CRISIS CREATED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION.
THAT IS WHY IT IS COMING.
>> Laura: NO, THEY ARE COMING
BECAUSE OBAMA-BIDEN DID NOTHING
TO CHANGE THE ASYLUM LAWS.
AND BECAUSE TODAY'S DEMOCRATS IN
THE HOUSE REFUSED TO DO THAT, AS
WELL.
NOW, AS YOU KNOW, THIS PAST
WEEK, I SAW FIRSTHAND THE L
SECTIONS OF TEXAS, AND HOW
OVERWHELMED THE BORDER CONTROL
IS.
PROCESSING CENTERS THERE HAVE
ESSENTIALLY BECOME DAY CARE
CENTERS.
>> WE HAVE TO PRETTY MUCH TRY
AND GET A HOLD OF EVERY TYPE OF
FORMULA WE CAN SO THAT WE CAN
GET THAT CHILD TO TAKE FEUD.
THEY USUALLY GET HERE
MALNOURISHED.
IF THEY AREN'T ALREADY SICK WITH
SOME KIND OF RESPIRATORY VIRUS,
WE HAVE TO REMOVE FROM THE FIELD
PATROL TO FILL THE BOTTLES.
THE GOOD THING IS, MANY OF US
ARE PARENTS, SO WE KNOW HOW TO
CHANGE DIAPERS, WE KNOW HOW TO
DEFEAT BOTTLES, BUT WE DO NOT
HAVE A STAFF SPECIFICALLY FOR
THAT.
>> Laura: IT IS A COMPLETE AND
UTTER SCANDAL.
A DISGUSTING ABDICATION OF
CONGRESSIONAL RESPONSIBILITY.
WHILE DEMOCRATS ACTUALLY DENY
THIS REALITY, TRUMP HAS TAKEN
SERIOUS STEPS TO ADDRESS THE
BORDER CRISIS.
HIS PLAN TO SEND ASYLUM-SEEKERS
BACK TO MEXICO AS THEY AWAIT
HEARINGS WAS ORIGINALLY BLOCKED
BY A FEDERAL DISTRICT COURT, BUT
THIS WEEK, THE NINTH CIRCUIT
RULED THAT THE POLICY CAN
CONTINUE, AT LEAST TEMPORARILY.
THAT IS GOOD NEWS.
THEY ARE ALSO TRAINING 200
BORDER PATROL AGENTS TO DO
ENHANCED ASYLUM SCREENINGS RIGHT
AT THE BORDER.
BUT EXPECT A COURT CHALLENGE
EVENTUALLY TO THAT, AS WELL.
AN IMMIGRATION PLAN IS GOING TO
BE RELEASED NEXT WEEK BY THE
ADMINISTRATION, AND FROM WHAT I
HEAR, I'M GOING TO LIKE SOME
THINGS IN IT, AND PROBABLY NOT
LIKE SOME OTHER THINGS IN IT.
BUT AT LEAST THE PRESIDENT IS
FACING THE REALITY OF WHAT HAS
TO BE DONE HEAD ON, AND HE KNOWS
HE NEEDS DEMOCRATIC VOTES TO DO
IT.
AND WHILE BROTHER JOE WANTS TO
EXTEND HEALTH RIGHTS TO
CITIZENS, LOOK AT THIS MAP IN
HOUSTON THE OTHER NIGHT WHEN WE
WERE LEAVING THE STUDIO.
RAYMOND ARROYO SAW THIS AND SAID
LET'S STOP YOU THOSE ARE
HOMELESS AMERICANS ON THE
STREETS OF THE CITY, AND IT WAS
POURING RAIN.
A HUGE FLOOD IN HOUSTON
YESTERDAY, TERRIBLE WEATHER, AND
IT STARTED THE NIGHT BEFORE.
MY QUESTION LOOKING AT THIS, IT
WAS HEARTBREAKING.
SHOULDN'T WE BE CARING FOR OUR
OWN CITIZENS, BEFORE WE TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE CITIZENS
OF A FOREIGN COUNTRY?
I'M SPEAKING A FOREIGN
COUNTRIES, ON THE TRADE FRONT,
NO PRESIDENT IN DECADES HAS BEEN
AS DOGGED OR TAUGHT AT
NEGOTIATING DEALS THAT ARE FAIR
TO AMERICAN BUSINESSES AND
WORKERS AS BEFORE.
>> UNDER THE PREVIOUS
ADMINISTRATION, THE
UNITED STATES LOST NEARLY A
QUARTER OF A MILLION
MANUFACTURING JOBS.
YOU REMEMBER THAT.
THEY LET OTHER COUNTRIES RAID
OUR FACTORIES, STEAL OUR JOBS,
AND ROB US BLIND.
OTHER THAN THAT, THEY WERE VERY
NICE.
THEY ALLOWED CHINA FREELY LOOT
OUR ECONOMY, PLUNDER OUR
INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY, AND
TARGET OUR INDUSTRIES OR
DESTRUCTION.
THAT IS WHAT WAS HAPPENING.
>> Laura: TRUMP HAS BEEN
RELENTLESSLY NEGOTIATING A DEAL
WITH CHINA, DRIVING A HARD
BARGAIN PAIRED BEIJING ATTEMPTED
TO DELAY THE NEGOTIATION
SCHEDULED IN D.C. THIS WEEK.
>> ONCE THE TARIFFS WENT UNDER,
THEY UPPED THE MEETING.
IT WAS SUPPOSED TO TAKE PLACE
ORIGINALLY ON THURSDAY, THEN
ABOUT FIVE WEEKS AGO, THEY SAID
HOW ABOUT FRIDAY, HOW ABOUT NEXT
WEEK?
I SAID WHAT IS THIS ALL ABOUT?
OKAY, DON'T WORRY ABOUT IT,
LET'S TAKEN 100 BILLION A YEAR.
WE PUT THE TARIFFS, WE MADE THE
STATEMENT, AND THEY UPPED THE
MEETING PAIRED HOW ABOUT, LET'S
GO BACK TO THURSDAY?
I'M REPRESENTING THE USA, AND HE
IS REPRESENTING CHINA.
AND WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE TAKEN
ADVANTAGE OF ANY MORE.
WE ARE GOING TO FIND OUT ABOUT
CHINA TONIGHT, AND I THINK IN
THE END, YOU ARE GOING TO BE
VERY IMPRESSED.
>> Laura: WELL, WHILE TRUMP IS
ENGAGING THE CHINESE AND HOLDING
OUT FOR THE BEST DEAL FOR
AMERICA, RAMBLING JOE IS ONCE
AGAIN IN DENIAL.
>> CHINA IS GOING TO EAT OUR
LUNCH?
COME ON, MAN.
THEY CAN'T EVEN FIGURE OUT HOW
TO DEAL WITH THE FACT THAT THEY
HAVE THIS GREAT DIVISION BETWEEN
THE CHINA SEA AND THE MOUNTAINS
IN THE EAST -- I MEET IN THE
LAST.
THAT THEY ARE NOT BAD FOLKS,
FOLKS.
BUT GUESS WHAT?
THEY ARE NOT COMPETITION FOR OUR
SPIRITS BE ONE OH, MY GOD.
IT WOULD BE SAD IF IT WEREN'T SO
INFURIATING, AND BASICALLY JUST
EMBARRASSING.
OBAMA AND BIDEN STOOD BY WHILE
CHINA CONTINUED TO CHEAT AND
STEAL US BLIND IN THE
UNITED STATES.
IF JOE EVER HAS POWER AGAIN, IT
WOULD BE BACK TO BUSINESS AS
USUAL WITH CHINA.
IN OTHER WORDS, CHINA WINS, WE
LOSE.
BUT WHAT ABOUT THE OTHER 2020
DEMOCRAT HOPEFULS?
IF YOU THINK THEY HAVE BETTER
IDEAS, YOU WOULD BE WRONG.
TAKE MAYOR PETE, LAST SEEN IN A
VOLGA MAGAZINE SHOOT, WITH ALL
OF HIS VAST EXPERIENCE IN
INTERNATIONAL TRADE, HE IS
WEIGHING IN ON THE CHINA
NEGOTIATIONS, AS WELL.
>> CHINA OFTEN WORKS IN TERMS OF
TWENTY-YEAR PLANS.
I'M NOT SURE THIS PRESIDENT
THINKS BEYOND HIS NEXT WHEAT,
AND IT SHOWS IN OUR POLICIES
WHEN IT COMES TO TRADE, WE NEED
A FAIR TRADE.
THERE IS CURRENCY MANIPULATION,
INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY THEFT, A
LOT OF BAD BEHAVIOR GOING ON ON
THE CHINESE SIDE.
IF WE WANT TO REDUCE THAT, THERE
HAS TO BE SOME SENSE WE ARE
GOING TO COME TO THE TABLE AND
NEGOTIATE SOMETHING BETTER, NOT
JUST LOBBING TARIFFS OVER THE
FENCE.
>> Laura: A SIDE OF THE FACT
THAT ONE DOES NOT LOBBING
TARIFFS AND THERE IS NO FENCE,
WHAT DOES HE THINK TRUMP AND BOB
LIGHTHIZER, THE ENTIRE TRADE
TEAM, HAVE BEEN DOING ALL OF
THIS TIME?
READING "HOLD" MAGAZINE?
TEAM TRUMP SUCCESSFULLY
NEGOTIATED THE TRADE DEAL WITH
SOUTH KOREA.
HE DIDN'T HAVE TO OVER, AND IS
NOW ON TO THE CROWN JEWEL OF
CHINA, AND IT IS GOING TO BE
HARD, IT MIGHT NOT BE POSSIBLE.
THE ONLY REASON, BY THE WAY,
THAT CHINA IS IN TOWN TONIGHT?
TRUMP'S TARIFFS.
>> THAT YOUNG MAN, BUTTIGIEG.
BOOT-EDGE-EDGE.
THEY SAY "EDGE-EDGE."
HE WILL BE GREAT.
REPRESENTING US AGAINST
PRESIDENT XI OF CHINA, THAT WILL
BE GREAT.
THAT WILL BE GREAT.
I WANT TO BE IN THAT ROOM, I
WANT TO WATCH THAT LINE.
>> Laura: WELL, FOR THE SAKE
OF THE COUNTRY, LET'S HOPE IT IS
A SCENE NONE OF US EVER SEE.
THE COUNTRY CAN'T AFFORD ANOTHER
DEMOCRAT IN THE OVAL OFFICE
RIGHT NOW.
ESPECIALLY NOT FROM THIS
RADICALIZED VERSION OF THE
DEMOCRAT PARTY.
THEY ARE NOT ONLY BEREFT OF
POLICIES THAT WORK, THAT ARE
PRACTICAL, THEY DON'T EVEN
RECOGNIZE THE VERIFIABLE THREATS